but it's crazy that you're in a film
where you're in a show with Jenna fish
with Pam because the one of the EPS of
dream Corp is Jim from the office John
Krasinski really yeah oh that's weird
and he's awesome yeah he's great yeah
yeah I read I love that movie quite
place oh he wrote it and he started that
movie was immediately [ __ ] amazing
yeah it's really really good did you see
hereditary yes stop everyone stop
everyone stop you two would you like it
I don't want to be honest with me I
don't know if I know what happened
during it but we do like the movie when
you walked out I was very shook me too
yeah I didn't like I was very
uncomfortable yeah me too yeah I just
saw very similar vibes I think Enter the
Void you seen that oh don't watch it why
it's this movie by this guy gasp his
first time is gasper by the way
Gasper no I think no he did the movie
love yeah he did so much yeah some of
his stuff is like normal palpable stuff
and another stuff is like this movies
like about a guy who dies while tripping
on DMT oh I've been through like Tokyo
what basically like watching his
existence and like he's like a spirit
rolling through so he sees his sister
and the [ __ ] she's going through and
like it's [ __ ] gnarly it doesn't ever
let up and you're like what else what
else can we have and then it's like oh
here's a live abortion that we're going
to show you why swear together it's not
even that none of this is funny
yeah yeah and then end usually live
abortions are funny but yeah but not
this one not the way they show yeah and
then you have that should be there's no
there was no color guy and then it ends
with you you're in a vagina yes he's
coming at you so you're in like oh no no
penis head coming at you yeah and then
it's like please don't come on me and
then it comes on you know they shall
come yeah oh you're bathed in it by the
end it's yeah I saw as a viewer you're
bathed in calm uh-huh I science
for 4d guys so you wouldn't recommend
that it's really it's a real rough
there's also two hours in fact 30
minutes like way too long it's very
there's no they don't let you up and
that was the same with hereditary just
like please let me out of this movie and
then like oh yeah you can summon up her
[ __ ] own neck yeah yes so gnarly
so gnarly yeah I found that movie to be
and people say there's a piece of [ __ ]
listen I got people all the time I had
comics I've had comics call I walked out
or I hated that movie or I'm like I saw
it three times no theater that's how
much I love that movie I liked it I want
it I like that type of stuff yeah it's
not I wouldn't feel good yeah it's not
good I don't need it to be a feel-good
movie yeah
[Music]